[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire pour
débattre discuter et réfléchir sur les
grands enjeux qui font l'actualité
le thème de ce soir l'autonomie et la
dépendance
en 2030 le nombre de personnes en perte
d'autonomie en france atteindra 1,6
millions en 2060 ce sera 2 45 millions
une perte d'autonomie qui concerne
notamment les personnes âgées pour les
yvelines selon une étude de l'insee
d'ici 2050 le nombre d'habitants âgés de
75 ans et plus pourraient atteindre près
de 200000 une population susceptible
donc de perte de l'autonomie c'est donc
le thème de notre soirée
comment favoriser cette autonomie le
plus longtemps possible
cette semaine encore trois invités sont
ceux pour sont avec nous par non pour
échanger sur ce sujet anne baekeland
bonsoir vous êtes chargé de projet de
santé publique à l'institut de promotion
de la santé de saint quentin en yvelines
priscilla lopes vos soir bonsoir vous
êtes la directrice d'aude avis une
plateforme d'accès aux services de
maintien à domicile et est en visio avec
nous carole peau mais on bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes la responsable du
développement de l'association habitat
et humanisme
alors la sécurité sociale va se doter
d'une cinquième branche celle de
l'autonomie c'est ce qu'a voté
l'assemblée nationale en juin dernier un
milliard d'euros serait attribuée pour
financer la perte d'autonomie des
personnes âgées et handicapées dans le
budget de la sécurité sociale pour 2021
nicolas landry a rencontré brigitte
bourguignon la ministre déléguée en
charge de l'autonomie
[Musique]
l'autonomie c'est tout ce qu'on peut
mettre en place dans les politiques
publiques politiques locales pour faire
en sorte que les personnes puissent agir
selon leur choix
malgré une perte d'autonomie parfois un
handicap ou un accident de la vie faire
en sorte que la vie sain climat plutôt à
la personne que l' inverse
moi c'est ça l'autonomie c'est pouvoir
être guidé par vos propres choix
quelle que soit la situation
[Musique]
l'indépendance c'est évidemment le
moment où cette autonomie et perdu voire
parfois définitivement
et là pour le coup il faut aussi qu'on
ait les structures adaptées pour
accompagner cette dépendance faire en
sorte que les choses viennent à vous et
pas l inverse
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est dans un virage
démographique très important et nous
devons tous avoir l'esprit ce n'est pas
un problème qui va arriver dans 20 ou 30
ans mais bien dans 10 ans et à peine dix
ans le même dans cinq ans on aura
énormément besoin d'avoir réfléchi bien
en amont pour accueillir toutes les
personnes âgées de 75 à 85 ans qui
arrive là inéluctablement
donc il faut qu'on adapte à la fois le
domicile pour que les personnes puissent
rester chez elles aussi longtemps que
possible qu'on puisse aussi réfléchir à
des dispositifs qu'on a vu aujourd'hui
d'habitat partagé de colocation qui ne
sont pas des solutions uniques qui aime
énormément de solutions diverses et
variées pour faire en sorte que les
personnes dont on reste à domicile
ensuite faire en sorte que les
établissements qui accueillent les
personnes plus dépendantes
parce que la vie a fait qu'elles seront
plus dépendantes aujourd'hui et bien
soit mieux armé pour le faire plus
ouvert aussi vers l'extérieur faire en
sorte que tout ça s'articule mais ne
soit pas cloisonner elle sa demande
aussi une réflexion des collectivités
locales elle même parce qu'il faut
qu'elle réfléchisse au fait que ces
personnes doivent être intégrés dans
leur centre ville dans leur centre bourg
pour que tout ça s'articule bien et que
les personnes gardent leur place
jusqu'au bout dans la société
[Musique]
on ne part pas d'une feuille blanche
comme vous le savez on parle de rapports
divers et de travail parlementaire aussi
depuis deux ans nous sommes attelés bien
sûr à la tâche dès le départ aujourd'hui
on est quasiment dans l'opérationnel une
dernière concertation qu'on doit avoir
entre financeurs et puis aussi pour ne
pas avoir une idée plaquer mais une idée
co-construite maintenant de ce que peut
faire de cette belle loi autonomie qui
ne doit pas être réduite seulement à
trouver des dispositifs différents mais
on doit travailler à la fois sont les
métiers sur l'habitat comme vous l'avez
vue sur toute l' approche domiciliaire
sur les établissements qui doit se
reconvertir un peu et puis aussi sont là
personne parce qu'on ne parle pas
souvent de la personne qui devons
redevenir le centre du dispositif
le vieillissement de la population est
effective sur tout le territoire
français et c'est une problématique on
voit aussi à saint quentin en yvelines
plus de 9000 saint quentinois ou 75 ans
et plus c'est toujours des chiffres
d'actualité oui alors le lit ps un
institut promouvant la santé qui est
donc le service santé de saint quentin
en yvelines mène effectivement un
mission d'observation de l'état socio
démographiques et sanitaires de la
population et donc on peut relever
effectivement d une hausse de l' indice
de vieillissement sur à peu près toutes
les communes même si le territoire est
moins marquée par le vieillissement que
le département ou la région pour faire
danser une tendance à augmenter sa voix
légèrement hâlé et reste ça augmente
alors les gens effectivement en fallait
les plus populations qui sont dû
s'installer dans les années 70 c'est
qu'ils ont trouvé
une qualité de vie sur saint-quentin ils
sont restés ont vieilli sur le
territoire maintenant un territoire il
est aussi il ya des indicateurs qui
permet de relever qu'un territoire reste
jeune par l'apport de population plus
jeune mais une augmentation de la
population de l'âge de la population et
de toute façon un indicateur qui est
d'actualité à cet interne yvelines et
justement cette veille de santé publique
ça vous permet d'imaginer les politiques
de demain à mettre en place
alors la veille de santé publique à
travers différents outils comme le
tableau de bord santé par exemple qui
est en cours d'actualisation
actuellement permet de relever qu'il ya
des fragilités notamment par exemple
pour les problématiques qui sont liées
au vieillissement comme les les
affections de longue durée qui sont des
affections qui nécessite un traitement
prolongé et coûteux ce sont des
caractéristiques voilà qui sont assez
prégnante sur le territoire avec des
disparités entre les communes et
quelquefois même dans les communes au
sein voilà vous aider voilà entre les
quartiers au sein des communes
donc on a effectivement des prévalences
en terme de maladies chroniques en terme
de maladies cardiovasculaires de diabète
de certains cancers également avec des
prévalences qui sont plus importantes à
saint-quentin que dans le département
priscilla lopes vous lancer en 2015 au
d'avis une plateforme de mise en
relation qui facilite le maintien à
domicile
est-ce que ça devient vraiment une
problématique est ce qu'aujourd'hui on
cherche à ce que les gens restent le
plus longtemps chez soi chez eux pardon
c'est compliqué le voilà les témoignages
de des dents de personnes personnes
âgées personnes handicapées c'est c'est
compliqué c'est le parcours du
combattant je ne sais pas à qui
m'adresser
et c'est c'est pourquoi au d'avis a
souhaité donc accompagner les personnes
personnes âgées et surtout les aidants
familiaux à trouver les bons services
d'aidé à domicile et voilà à apporter
une visibilité sur les différentes
solutions qui s'offrent à eux et on a
fait le pari de pouvoir les accompagner
à travers donc les les intercommunalités
les communes les hôpitaux parce que la
relation humaine reste importante
vous le disiez c'est compliqué ça peut
être long
c'est une question que nous on a posé à
nos téléspectateurs chaque semaine on
fait un sondage cette semaine la
question c'était hésitez vous a placé un
proche dans un établissement spécialisé
et c'est le oui qui requiert plus dessus
le plus de suffrages hearing ça ne vous
étonne pas priscilla lopes ah bah non
effectivement c'est vraiment une volonté
que de vouloir rester rester à domicile
mais encore faut-il pouvoir coordonner
l'ensemble des solutions et
et voilà et pouvoir trouver aussi les
aides financières qui vont de pair avec
ses solutions
alors on va le voir tout au long de
cette émission il ya de nombreuses
solutions qui sont mises en place pour
limiter au maximum le placement d'un
proche carole pour mais o'shea habitat
et humanisme
on travaille sur le logement collectif
sur l'habitat inclusif un habitat qui
vous a donné des résultats auxquels vous
ne vous attendiez peut-être pas le look
et le lien social ralenti la dépendance
tout à fait nous sommes une association
d'insertion par le logement donc en fait
on a beaucoup travaillé sur la question
de l' isolement en développement des
habitats collectifs comme les pensions
de famille face à la montée du
vieillissement et aussi de la situation
des familles monoparentales qui sont
dans des situations d'isolement
importante on a depuis dix ans développé
on appelle des habitats père
générationnel qui logent des publics
d'âge différent donc des personnes âgées
des familles monoparentales et des
jeunes en insertion et en fait à travers
ce travail qui était un travail de lutte
contre l'isolément et de solidarité les
plus pauvres je me suis rendu compte en
assistant à différents séminaires des
agences régionales de santé qu'on était
à un véritable acteur de la santé
publique car dans les déterminants de
santé
la question du lien social du sentiment
d'utilité du cadre de vie de l'insertion
dans son quartier contribue fortement à
prévenir la perte d'autonomie
donc on est heureux de participer aussi
à cette politique de santé publique
qu'on va essayer de d'approfondir
notamment puisque effectivement vous
indiquer que la présence de services à
proximité des personnes contribuent
aussi à les rassurer et contribuer aussi
à prévenir la perte d'autonomie donc
l'expérience de davie est tout à fait
intéressante et nous souhaitons nous
aussi être le ferment de la mise en
place de ses plateformes dans les
différents départements de france est-ce
que aussi le faite vous parlez des
maisons intergénérationnelles il y en a
une à jouer en josas
le fait d'être avec des plus jeunes qui
seront peut-être plus attentif d'un
déclin de santé fait que les gens sont
peut-être pris plus tôt si on ne parle
que de l'aspect santé oui ce qui se
passe c'est que dans ces habitats dans
chacun un logement individuel on peut
avoir aussi quelques colocation mais
c'est plutôt du logement privatif et
surtout on a des espaces communs
partagés dans tous nos immeubles ou des
animations sont organisées par des
bénévoles
et depuis que qui existent le forfait
habitat inclusif on va aussi pouvoir
renforcer une présence salariés qui
organise des animations fait vivre la
maison et en fait on se rend compte
qu'il ya des liens qu'on ne maîtrise pas
qu'ils se créent entre les locataires et
une espèce de veille sociale qui
s'instaure
et qui permet aux personnes âgées d'être
rassurés c'est à dire que si la personne
âgée ne descendent pas dans les espaces
communs il ya quelqu'un qui va
s'inquiéter de savoir comment il va et
c'est donc il ya des liens presque
fraternelle qui peuvent se nouer entre
les uns et les autres et qui sont très
rassurants c'est sacré ça recréer un
esprit un peu de villages voire certains
parlent même d'un esprit de famille
voilà qui après en terme de stimulation
pour les personnes âgées c'est des
maisons il ya des enfants des jeunes
dont il ya aussi la question de l'accès
au numérique où les uns et les autres
peuvent s'entraider
il ya la question de la nutrition ou si
on sait que dans la question de la perte
d'autonomie ya ce sujet là qui nous pose
pour des personnes âgées isolées qui
finissent par ce mal se nourrir et bien
dans ces maisons l'espace commun autant
me dire qu'en général c'est une grande
cuisine collective et c'est l'occasion
partage des aussi des repas tous
ensemble voilà un jack lang sur
cinquante ans dennis vinyle ya aussi des
structures
je pense notamment aux méventes et qui
pilote et qui fait beaucoup de projets
alors le maire en tête effectivement
c'est le site qui va réunir une offre de
services globale et et variés pour
répondre aux besoins des personnes qui
sont en perte d'autonomie
donc on va y trouver au d'avis bien sûr
on va y trouver également des accueils
de jour pour personnes en situation de
handicap vieillissantes ou atteints
d'une pathologie cognitif de telles
qu'alzheimer on va avoir également sur
place le service de soins infirmiers à
domicile qui va réaliser au domicile des
personnes en perte d'autonomie des soins
de confort et d'hygiène
on va également y trouver une équipe
spécialisée alzheimer qui va au domicile
c'est une équipe pluridisciplinaire qui
va au domicile soutenir les personnes
atteintes de cette maladie ou d'une
maladie apparentée
et puis on a un centre de formation
également qui va lui former des futurs
accompagnateurs professionnels de santé
et puis j'ai peut-être oublié
une structure un service d'aidé à
domicile sur place également dont on a
là une offre vraiment global et
réfléchie pour soutenir à la fois les
personnes qui ont ou qui sont en perte
d'autonomie mais également leurs aidants
j'imagine que ça aide aussi quand tout
est rassemblé
parce que ça communique pour pouvoir
amener vers les meilleurs services et
que certains saint quentinois ne se
retrouvent pas enfermer un peu chez eux
bien sûr même si ces services ont des
missions des rôles un peu différent le
fait d'être rassemblés au sein d'une
même structure
ça favorise bien sûr la coordination ça
favorise les transmissions
d'informations parce que quelquefois il
peut y avoir des personnes qui sont
suivis par différents dispositifs est
donc cette coordination est favorisée
par le fait d'être réunis au même
endroit précis dagnaud ps je voudrais
rebondir sur plusieurs choses qui ont
déjà été dites ce que vous êtes une
plate forme mais oh mes rentes et vous
proposer aussi des ateliers des
conférences autour du bien vieillir qui
avait l'idée de l'alimentation l'idée du
sport de marché ça dépasse les simples
services en fait oui tout à fait en fait
on va proposer un certain nombre
d'ateliers de conférences sur des
thématiques mensuelles ce mois-là sur
les différents thèmes qu'on a qu'on a pu
évoquer on est aussi en cours de
conception d'un escape game qui va
permettre de
présenté l'intérêt des aides techniques
d'une évolution du logement pour qu'ils
soient plus sécurisé qui soit plus
confortable
l'intérêt aussi de recourir par exemple
à une ergothérapeute qui va pouvoir
donner des astuces et conseils très
pratico pratiques pour améliorer le
quotidien donc des personnes personnes
âgées personnes handicapées
est-ce que parmi les solutions on est en
2020 maintenant la technologie ont la
vie elle est avec nous tous les jours
est ce que la domotique peut amener à
rester plus longtemps chez soi et c'est
sur la domotique apporte beaucoup de
meilleur
meilleure sécurité à domicile on peut
par exemple vérifier si le frigo a été
ouvert aujourd'hui s'il a pas été
ouverts c'est un signal d' alerte donc
voilà en fait on peut vraiment assuré en
complémentarité de services d'aidé à
domicile de solutions techniques de
domotique
une offre qui permettent un de rester
chez soi plus longtemps mais alors on
parle de personnes dépendantes ce sont
souvent des personnes âgées
est ce que justement la domotique ne les
effraie pas va t'en dire je ne sais pas
comment ça marche si ça tombe en panne
qu'est ce que je fais ou pas du tout
c'est un cliché
alors avant ça je pense que déjà il ya
aulas la domotique ça va coûter cher ça
c'est le premier premier réflexe or il
peut quand même y avoir des aides il
peut et puis tout n'est pas forcément
très cher ya des dispositifs qui sont
chères il y en a d'autres qui sont
beaucoup plus accessibles
maintenant si la personne est accompagné
e
ça peut aussi très bien se passer c'est
devenir social toujours en vacances on
vient de dire il ya aussi le coût de ce
que ça peut être de placer quelqu'un on
sait qu'une en 2018 le coût médian
mensuel d'une chambre individuelle en
ehpad c'est 1977 euros home est renté on
informe sur toutes les aides aussi
j'imagine il ya des aides il faut
s'informer là dessus ça évite d'être
placé peut-être alors le maire hantait
et puis je dirais en premier lieu le
département à travers les pôles
autonomie territoriaux qui ont cette
mission d'accompagner et de mettre en
place au côté la personne un plan daide
en réunissant toutes les ressources
possibles pour compléter les revenus de
la personne elle
donc je dirais que le mes rentes et bien
sûr connaît les dispositifs mais c'est
le département qui est vraiment chef de
file dans les politiques qui sont mises
en oeuvre en faveur des personnes âgées
les personnes en situation de handicap
et puis les communes également c'est
souvent la première porte d'entrée pour
accéder à ces informations
donc les ccas ont tout à fait aussi
informe et accompagne les personnes à la
mise en place de deux dossiers de
demande de financement
carole baumes et ont depuis quelques
temps habitat et humanisme travaille
avec l'association la pierre angulaire
il y à un réseau des pâtes dans les
yvelines rihanna notamment à versailles
saint paul gérontologique et on trouve
un accueil de jour
c'est une autre offre pour trouver une
autre solution encore oui effectivement
donc la pierre angulaire fait partie du
réseau d'habitat et humanisme
avec 40 ehpad et donc tu as tous est en
jeu aujourd'hui de développer des
plateformes gérontologique au niveau du
territoire qui peuvent s'appuyer
effectivement sur un ehpad donc c'est le
cas de delépine à versailles on a un
ehpad avec 113 chambre pour résidents un
accueil de jour alzheimer il ya aussi un
accompagnement pour personnes
désorientées à domicile est
effectivement un service de soins
infirmiers à domicile etc
c'est vraiment le aujourd'hui de tout
l'enjeu ce qu'on m'a autour de l'habitat
puisque nous on est au démarrage un
acteur de l'habitat mais c'est d'arriver
à développer ce genre d'expérience sur
versailles s'est particulièrement
innovant puisque c'est une société
coopérative à la fois publiques et
privées qui a été créé avec la mairie de
versailles et le ccs de versailles et
c'est vrai que tout l'enjeu aujourd'hui
au niveau du du territoire c'est
d'arriver à avoir cette offre de
services qui rassure les personnes âgées
qui accompagne évidemment celles qui
sont dépendantes mais qui peut aussi
rassuré à travers une veille celles qui
commencent à manifester et signes de
fragilité
donc par exemple en france j'ai vu qu'il
y avait des plateformes où il y avait
aussi un soutien pour le maintien à
domicile
donc je pense à ça par rapport à la
domotique d'antan on parle et on peut
imaginer que sur ces plateformes il ya
aussi une visite pour vérifier que tout
fonctionne bien pour aider les personnes
âgées à s'approprier les nouveaux outils
numériques enfin il ya beaucoup de
choses à inventer et qui ne pourront se
faire qu'à travers la coordination de
tous les acteurs impliqués sur ce sujet
on a parlé aussi de l'alimentation du
lien social il ya une notion qui depuis
2010 7 permet aussi de
muté l'aggravation ou l'arrivée de
pathologie c'est le sport tu sur
ordonnance et à saint quentin en
yvelines s'est depuis avril 2018 c'est
quel est le principe du sport sur
ordonnance c'est pas pour tout le monde
alors ces réserves est effectivement un
certain public donc le dispositif sport
santé sur ordonnance qui est développé à
saint-quentin s'appuie sur la loi qui
est paru donc en 2016 et qui permet la
prescription par un médecin prescription
donc médical d'une activité physique
adaptée comme moyen thérapeutique à part
entière c'est d'ailleurs reconnu par la
haute autorité de santé comme un moyen
thérapeutique vraiment à part entière
donc le dispositif qui est développé à
saint quentin vous le disiez depuis
avril 2018 vient compléter un des
dispositifs qui sont déjà mis en place
et va s'adresser à des personnes qui
souffrent d'une ou de plusieurs
affections de longue durée qui ont
d'hypertension artérielle qui ont un
surpoids ou l'obésité
et puis on le disait puisque le le lien
social vous le 10e adam est très
important ça va favoriser aussi la perte
d'autonomie des personnes âgées
ça va limiter le risque de chute
donc c'est un dispositif vraiment global
qui est destiné à l'ensemble de ces
personnes et qui doit réduire ou en tout
cas réduire l'apparition ou la
l'aggravation des facteurs de risque
liés aux maladies chroniques mais ça va
permettre aussi de réduire le stress
d'anxiété des réduire peut-être des des
signes de dépression également le lien
social étant un des facteurs
effectivement de réduction de ses
risques aux côtés de l'activité physique
qui elle est adaptée à la fois aux
possibilités la personne et à sa
pathologie président lopez
on les a nommés vite fait tout à l'heure
mais grâce aussi à votre plateforme vous
êtes là pour les aidants parce que
derrière une personne en perte
d'autonomie il ya souvent une famille
qui peut vite être dépassée oui
effectivement il ya 11 millions
d'aidants en france la majorité sont des
femmes
la majorité sont
actif donc voilà il ya véritablement un
besoin d'accompagner ces personnes parce
qu'elles sont enfin ils sont déjà très
occupés très très pris par par par leur
vie de tous les jours et vient en plus
d'ajouter cette période de stress
valasse ce besoin d'être accompagné pour
pouvoir trouver les bonnes solutions et
pour pouvoir voilà résoudre un certain
nombre de problèmes ils réagissent à la
fois donc dans les dans les tâches
quotidiennes mais aussi pour trier les
papiers pour aller trouver des
différentes solutions
voilà il ya des portes d'entrée qui
s'ouvre comme les communes mais voilà
toutes les communes ne sont pas
forcément doté de deux ccas ou de houe
voilà deux personnes qui ont toutes les
informations et donc le but de davie
s'est véritablement d'accompagner donc
c'est ces collectivités pour qu'il
puisse avoir une meilleure visibilité
des opportunités qui s'offrent donc à
ces familles est derrière de pouvoir
faire des enquêtes de satisfaction de
manière régulière une fois qu' il y à
une solution qui est mise en place pour
véritablement s'assurer du bon
fonctionnement des solutions qui ont été
mises en place carole pour mais on a vu
quelques solutions qu'on pourrait mettre
en place dès aujourd'hui mais est-ce
qu'à habitat humanisme
on réfléchit à d'autres idées d'autres
d'autres solutions et le les pistes
justement sur lesquels on travaille
aujourd'hui sont celles que j'ai
évoquées qui sont pas seulement
travailler sur le
[Musique]
le logement le lien social c'est notre
on et bâtisseur de lien c'est notre base
line on va dire mais c'est de mieux
travailler avec tous les partenaires du
territoire pour construire cette offre
de service auprès de la personne âgée
il ya aussi toute la question du
bénévolat nous on est très on a quatre
mille trois cents bénévoles dans le
mouvement
on est un mouvement bénévole et donc il
ya aussi toute la question de la
formation nos bénévoles pour sur ces
sujets de la perte d'autonomie et du
vieillissement qu' il y ait plus de
bénévoles aussi en ehpad c'est-à-dire
que les personnes qui sont en ehpad ont
du mal à sortir pour des questions de
mobilité et donc c'est intéressant que
ce soit la ville qui viennent à eux pour
décloisonner les dispositifs donc on a
aussi une réflexion poussée dans ce
domaine là décloisonner décloisonner et
décloisonnée on l'aura bien compris on
va s'arrêter sur une ces mots-là
décloisonner le lien social et surtout
ne pas hésiter à se renseigner
c'est la fin de cette société merci à
toutes les trois d'avoir été présente ce
soir vous pouvez revoir cette émission
sur notre site internet et notre
application au mobile on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]